oh you could hurt Joe Biden you know
again and get Trump elected
um you know people say that to me a lot
are you in any contact with the Democrat
Party I mean have you have they
specifically said we're not gonna I mean
I'm guessing they don't pick up your
calls right oh no we're not not in
contact with them I mean they've you
know been very clear that they don't
want me in this election I hear it from
people all the time
um you know you could hurt Joe Biden and
get Trump elected people say that to me
a lot you know people who are in the
party or uh you know I ran into Hillary
Clinton at a dinner a couple of weeks
ago and she said something like that to
me I don't think anybody is happy with
the choices that Americans are being
given right now